[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday October
Ella I think who knows anymore
gather not something she'd like to say
are you still working on your video jeez
it's like 10 o'clock at night yeah I
know I have to finish soon I don't know
if you know who Seth Godin is I don't
know who Seth Godin is currently he's
bald and famous
anyway somebody interviewed Seth Godin
and they asked him some questions I
guess that's what an interview is and
one of the questions that was asked was
concerning the fact that there are like
a hundred and seventy-five thousand
books published in America each year but
the average person buys like one book a
year how did we get to the point where
there are more and more books published
every year and less and less people
actually reading them maybe we should
talk about publishing less crap
anyway Seth Godin has had several
best-selling books so the interviewer
asks whether he thinks YouTube videos
are ever gonna someday surpass books as
being the most useful way to acquire new
information and Seth Godin says not only
will it be a better medium it already is
a better medium in fact for a lot of
topics YouTube videos hit way more
eyeballs than a book in that same topic
Everwood so why don't I sometimes say
things that are like important like
best-selling authors say things that are
important well John that's what I'm
gonna do today October 11th is National
Coming Out Day and I heartily encourage
any people who are hiding things about
themselves to let those things come free
today make it today do it today it's
coming out date let's come out sorry I
make in this video so late in the day
tomorrow is not National Coming Out Day
but if you didn't come out today and
you're watching this video and in fact
it is September 12th that's okay you can
still come out of the closet that is
alright if you're hiding something about
yourself you've got something that you
keep in a secret that the people you
love and respect deserve to know then
come out eleven twelve it doesn't matter
and I'm doing it with you I'm coming out
of the closet it's a non-traditional
closet but it's one that I've been in
and I'm going to come out of it now you
may have seen me wearing rancid shirts
you may have heard me talking about my
lifelong ambition to have a mohawk but I
am a gigantic fan of Japanese pop music
like really upbeat
like sickeningly sweet fast girly
Japanese pop music
and I'm asking all of you to not let
that knowledge change the way you see me
this doesn't mean that I don't like punk
rock - and it doesn't mean that I don't
want to hear your band's demo album all
it means is that sometimes I like to get
the Shinohara to Moy going on turn it up
to 11 and just like take off my clothes
and dance around my house in my
underwear that's all it means it's not
weird it's normal it's a normal
physiological thing and I'm ashamed of
the fact that I'm ashamed of it now this
is certainly not as difficult as coming
out as gay person well I am on YouTube
but leaving the decide this is much
easier but it is a little bit difficult
for me because I like to fancy myself
into the more hardcore stuff
Japanese pop music gets me going the
sickening sweetness of it all might also
explain my attraction to unicorns which
are prominently featured in Japanese pop
culture so while I may be ready to
accept that zombies are in fact more
awesome than unicorns but not for the
reasons that you proposed in your last
video I'm not ready to give up my spot
on Team Unicorn
John I will see you tomorrow